what did you say when you first met
Stephen King I don't remember that's the
thing is is I was all pumped somebody
has it on tape Warner Brothers filmed it
which was also making me feel really
weird Oh God
but I remember him coming through the
door and then I kind of black out for a
while and then I remember being in the
movie theatre with him which was
probably about a half hour later but I'm
sure I just kind of tripped over myself
and maybe said I have this habit I'm
learning where I meet when I get
starstruck I say the person's name to
them which is a really like bizarre
thing that I just am realizing I do do
you know how are you I don't even I
don't even have put a question on to it
I just say their own name it's turn to
you know not even a hey that's still a
sentence I just go to know Quentin
Tarantino and then nothing waiting for
you know I'm narrating this to someone
that's humble that's yeah that's like
what we need more of in life it's like
that moment were you a little kid really
I'm excited I don't get excited that
much so when I meet somebody that's one
of my it's just it's nice it's nice I
think even advertently do it and
hopefully you think people look at you
and go that's cool he likes me I hope so
I am I felt like I was getting better at
it for a while and and then I was on a
plane a couple weeks ago and Kurt
Russell was on the plane and I just lost
it Kurt Russell if I don't talk about
right rate horror movies one of the best
of all time that's one of the things
I've got in my in my little nerd room
that I'm really walk out of I've got
this really it's a great like one of a
kind don't say it's wider - ooh I love
this wouldn't that be great spider have
it'd be amazing but yeah I I'm god damn
that movies perfect it really is yeah
that one holds up John Carpenter went to
my College Western Kentucky University
and yeah ugh when he's talked about the
fog me bragging and name dropping
immediately no that's okay we can do
this I I'm gonna kick and we can do it
all dad he says like you know the fog is
moving towards State Street or whatever
he starts naming Street stats at Bowling
Green Kentucky awesome
yeah that's cool to me I think that's
awesome yeah right yeah so you just said
Stephen King a half an hour later he was
watching are you saying you didn't meet
Stephen King till after the movie was
made
yeah I yeah the the first time I met
Steve it was when I brought him Steve I
can say I'm allowed I
he made it clear that he was sick of me
just looking at him and saying the words
Stephen King so he you know he please
just just call me Steve
but the first time I met him is when I
brought him doctor sleep and I screened
the movie for him and he loved it he did
love it
you loved the shining the movie yes in
so many ways you look now I would think
that someone who loved the movie Steve
won't have a problem with directing the
sequel to the shining considering that
he didn't have a good relationship with
Kubrick considering that his screenplay
or the book was nothing like the movie
so you think there would be Stephen
King's or as you know him Steve would
just look at you and say let me ask you
a question did you like The Shining yep
thank you nice meeting you yeah it was
quite a it was quite a conversation and
I was so freaked out about it it
wouldn't have happened except he loved
Gerald's game and who doesn't love Jay
if you haven't seen it son Netflix still
right it is yes what a surprise because
you don't think that movies gonna yeah
well go ahead with the Stephen King star
we'll get into Gerald's game so he was
happy enough with that that when Warner
Brothers and said hey Flanagan might
want to do doctor sleep he was a great
but he didn't know what I wanted to do
with it which was kind of fold folded
into the Kubrick universe cuz you know
in the book like you said it's it's so
different they overlooked burned down
you know dick Halloran is alive
everything's different and so I had to
get in touch with them and say hey
before before we proceed on this before
you endorse it I just need your blessing
on something you might not like and his
initial reaction was like no I don't I
don't like that but what was it oh you
can't tell really cuz yeah I mean I
don't want you to tell too much I mean I
can tell a little bit at this point I
can I mean it's out its out tonight I
have even watched a trailer purpose only
Wow because I don't watch trailers
because there's something I'm not
excited about I want to be surprised by
everything all right that I'm gonna be
really careful I'll be really careful
yeah
so I pitched him a scene you'll know
which one when you see the film and I
said what what I want to do for me the
only difference I would make to the
doctor sleep novel is the location of
the third act and for me I thought that
would be awesome too
stage in the abandoned Overlook Hotel of
Kubrick's world and he had a lot of
questions about how that could work he
wasn't really keen on it but I pitched
him one scene and it wasn't King on it
and the pitch went over and he said okay
do that proceed but let me read it you
know so then it was about the scripts
and I sent the script and I freaked out
and he came back and said look I
actually really like this really yeah so
you got really one shot yeah so you had
the nail you had how many people read
this before you said okay I'm gonna give
it to Stephen to my producer Trevor Macy
who's produced everything I've done I've
killed oculus yeah so Trevor read it and
my wife read it and then I sent it off
to to King and then how long before I
responded almost two weeks
yeah well he I know it
was and he had he had written about a
day after he had received he's like look
I'm halfway through it and I love this
so far but my son Joe is getting married
so I gotta go do that it might be a
minute before I get back to you and
everything he was gonna hate was in the
back half so I was like oh so I
sweat bullets on that for a while but he
came back he loved it by then I had
given it to Warner Brothers and they'd
kind of all decided to do the movie and
when he finally came back and kind of
like yes you have my blessing to do this
draft he qualified it by saying look I
really love this and I think it's so
good in my experience this is not the
kind of movie a big studio will make and
I got to say right back like so funny
you say that
they'd greenlit it this morning off the
same draft you read and yeah but if he
if he hadn't had signed off on what we
wanted to do it when they made the film